told you Morty he still got it
you sons of... what's the job
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my Rick and Morty season 4
episode 3 video there were all kinds of
Easter eggs
it was mostly a send-up of heist movie
tropes and adventure treasure hunting
movie tropes so we'll break it down if
you're new to the channel I'm doing
videos for all the episodes this season
be sure to subscribe to get everything
we're also doing a weekly Rick and Morty
merch giveaway obviously careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the episode
yet we'll do top 10 WTF and Easter eggs
as we go along starting with number 10
the title one crew over the cuckoo's
Morty is obviously a reference to One
Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest with Jack
Nicholson but also the fact that Rick's
whole bit in the episode flew right over
Morty's head it was all about Rick
getting Morty to stop working on his
script and his plan was successful
number nine they opened with a big Star
Trek reference where Morty is trying to
free climb up a mountain base while Rick
is following him in a hover chair eating
an Arby's sandwich which I believe is
integration because they try to make
sure that you definitely see the Arby's
wrapper when it flies towards the camera
at the beginning of Star Trek by Kirk
also falls right off of the mountain and
Spock has to save him with the hover
boots then they turned it into a bit of
an Indiana Jones Raiders of the Lost Ark
parody with them trying to get a gem
from an alien tomb with a bunch of
elaborate traps that are all from
Raiders the Lost Ark all the traps that
they walk through wearing the anti booby
suits were from Raiders Rick uses the
entire episode starting with these
scenes to call out tropes of movies like
this either treasure hunting or mostly
heist movies in more than anything the
Ocean's eleven movies but there were a
couple of other different heist movies
that they were parroting your overall
enjoyment of the episode I think is
mostly predicated on having seen a lot
of heist movies or at least seeing the
Ocean's eleven movies so some of the
bits might not have landed quite as well
for you if you don't care about heist
movies or if you've never seen any of
them so for a number of reasons I don't
think this episode was quite as strong
as episode 1 and not quite as deep and
impactful as episode 2 there were also a
lot of Indiana Jones Kingdom of the
Crystal Skull references during this -
you could also call this dungeon built
by advanced aliens but made with really
old timey traps a bit of a reference to
kingdom of
Christel school but there's also an
actual Crystal Skull that they use
during the heist off later in the
episode everyone probably spotted the
Boulder Raiders reference was it trying
to chase them down but the anti boobies
is just bouncing it off and then
obviously Indiana Jones's hate of snakes
total waste of snakes which is also a
meta callback to get schwifty because
Rick keeps snakes hidden up his pants
legs number eight Rick breaks the fourth
wall again when they approached the tomb
when he says Morty should take a beat to
acknowledge the sacred atmosphere to
give their cynical grave-robbing a hint
of a reverence which is another heist
movie trope but they find out that
Rick's nemesis Michael Knightly beat him
to it leaving an origami horse which is
one of many Ocean's Twelve references to
the jackal character who was their
nemesis trying to one-up then the whole
time
Michael Knightly also kind of reminded
me of Michael Knight from Knight Rider
but I don't know if that was an
intentional reference with that name he
was voiced by Justin Theroux who you may
have recognized but he was actually the
second celebrity guest cameo during the
episode you probably recognized the
first one because when the body
rises from the tomb as they leave its
Claudia Black who's back for the first
time I think since season 1 when she
played the leader of the females but she
also breaks the fourth wall when she
calls out the ridiculous idea that who
builds a tomb that collapses on the
person that is there to protect 7 they
go to high scon to get the gem from his
nemesis but the convention itself is
mostly a parody of comic-con in real
life with Rick getting super frustrated
with badge registration and then not
being able to get into Hall H anyone who
has ever tried to get into comic-con or
even just by a regular badge or try to
get into Hall H probably feels seen it's
exactly like this it's super frustrating
the lines are super long is really crazy
we get our third celebrity guest cameo
in the woman at this desk it's Pamela
add lon
back again she did her Bobby Hill voice
from king of the hill in last week's
episode as the son of the fly mob boss
that Rick was threatening to get rid of Morty references Catherine alpha Jones which
is an Easter Egg for Catherine
zeta-jones who was in two of the Ocean's
eleven sequels and Zeta is the opposite
end of the Greek alphabet from alpha
they do the bit in the trailer about
Morty putting on too much pointment and
transforming into a huge winged creature
that Rick has to hunt down it's implied
that it's still our Morty though or at
least the same version of Morty
the beginning of the episode even though
when Rick was warning Morty he made it
sound like he'd have to hunt him down
and get rid of him if he put too much on
everyone grab another voucher for one
free replacement Morty but number six
the first crew they do their Ocean's
eleven montages rick is the George
Clooney character goes around assembling
his crew just so that he can get past
the door of Hall H all those weird
transitions are right out of Ocean's
eleven the big guy is a reference to
Livingston who was performing stand-up
in a comedy club when the George Clooney
character finds him the woman is a
reference to the robot hands at the
beginning of ghost in the shell' with
her confusing ass hands trunculus is a
reference to the brothers from Ocean's
eleven running a racecar track in the
race itself is a bit of a reference to
Wacky Races this guy looks like he's
right out of Mad Max fury road this guy
driving the banana car who himself is a
piece of fruit wearing a banana also
feels kind of like a Beverly Hills Cop
banana in the tailpipe joke but
trunculus an actual vampire voiced by
Ryan Ridley it's the second time that
he's done a vampire character he was
also the vampire in the post-credits
scenes from tiny Rick number 5 they do
their lab coat ripoff Doctor Strange
joke obviously dr. Strange's cloak of
levitation has a mind of its own and it
strangles people when dr. strange asks
it to so Rick does the same thing with
his lab coat but he's breaking the
fourth wall when he says rip off the
movie dr. strange the bit with the heist
contest is a reference to the contest
that they had during Ocean's Twelve with
the jackal obviously the Crystal Skull
is a reference to the Kingdom of the
Crystal Skull then Rick proceeds to call
out all the tired heist movie tropes he
hates with a bunch of competing montages
and twists with in twists throughout the
montage when they're doing all these
different reveals and bits the guy
that's secretly another guy all of these
are based on the real bits that they did
during Ocean's Twelve number four the
double-cross in the second crew so Rick
gets double-crossed by hyster tron which
is another trope of heist movies but
then assembles a totally random crew to
fight the algorithm that he used to
program heist a Tron and apparently the
Greek gods are real in the Rick and
Morty multiverse because he goes to get
the Greek god Hephaestus from one
reality mr. poopy b*tthole comes back
and apparently he's been a college
professor for some time now
Rick trains his students to attack him
which they later call out at the end of
the
episode wait a minute weren't you in a
hurry how did you spend all that time
training those people we get our next
big celebrity guest cameo in Elon Musk
playing Elon tusk and they just do a
tusk bit with all of regular Elon Musk's
stuff like he runs Tuscola instead of
Tesla all the jokes about them talking
and moving around his office and being
sorry about wasting time it's just a
joke about Elon Musk's efficiency he's
really big on being efficient he works
seven days a week so he hates wasting
time ventriloquist bits during the
episode with the arrows that turn other
people into ventriloquism dummies Rick
burns David Lynch in his movies when
referencing the inspiration for his
seemingly random plan he also wants to
play a lot of Minecraft but we've known
for previous episodes that Rick is a big
fan of Minecraft the last time he
referenced it during season 3 he made an
autism joke implying that he himself
might have autism because he likes
Minecraft but during this episode he
also calls Morty out for having
Asperger's so maybe he does
maybe that's Rick just saying that the
episode goes way over the top when the
heist robot starts doing bits from
Ocean's Twelve with the spy camera and
the giant pizza box when they all start
executing their random plans Morty
starts spasming out on the ground just
like he did at the end of the pilot
episode after shoving the mega seed up
his butt that number 3 Rick vs. hyster
tron final battle the bit of their final
battle went on a little too long but
it's just more of rick calling out heist
movie tropes over and over bits within
bits within bits trying to overload high
stat Ron to me number 2 the Netflix
jokes were just a little bit funnier
just because they were a little more
true to life morty almost successfully
sells his heist movie to netflix but
then realizes because of all the things
they've been through that it's a really
tired genre he kind of hates heist
movies now and he doesn't want to have
anything to do with it so he just kind
of leaves it aside even though the
Netflix executives are ready to buy the
pitch in the room that's mostly a joke
on the idea that Netflix will buy any
idea that you throw at them they have
the final reveal that Rick planned it
this whole way just so that Morty would
get disillusioned and stopped working on
his script which is a callback to the
new family power dynamic they introduced
in episode 1 with beth ordering rick not
to directly mess with Morty's hopes and
dreams which he doesn't
in number one the post credit scene is a
bit of a call back to mr. poopy
b*tthole's class and him calling out Rick
for succumbing to all the tropes that he
himself had been calling out the entire
episode like I said overall your
enjoyment of this episode probably just
depends on how much you like heist
movies and how many of these movies that
they're making fun of you've actually
seen if there's any Easter eggs you
spotted in the episode that I didn't
mention in the video just write them
below in the comments I'm working on a
trailer video for the next episode that
should post pretty soon but just a heads
up there is no new episode of Rick and
Morty next week episode 4 won't be for
two more weeks because of the
Thanksgiving holiday so no worries I'll
just remind people when I post my
trailer video congratulations Nick
Leonardi you're the giveaway winner from
my last Rick and Morty video please
email me on the about page of my channel
so I can get your details every one
click here for my Rick and Morty season 4 episode 2
video and click here for my
new Mandalorian episode 3 video thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight!